i am the head of the human resource  management and professional training  service in dgi tech  [Music]  i work for microsoft in romania and in  germany  the officials are seeing a bit  untouchable but actually there are  really nice friends and colleagues and  that's one of the best parts  there are so many opportunities if you  set your mind the direction you want to  you get the resources and you get the  help  [Music]  the european parliament i.t environment  is one of the most  advanced from what we can see in other  public organizations maybe it's one of  the well hidden secrets about the  institutions that there is strong i.t  behind it  give it a try we promise you will get  the challenges you are looking for  [Music]